was geht ab hier ist euer max und wir
haben ein problem
ja ich nehme jetzt die vierte folge
treten auf und es gibt scheinbar gleich
zwei teams november wird tagesaktuell
sind die sind wohl beide unten in der
höhle bei max ich bin oben erstmal sich
aber max hat unser ganzes equipment
unsere ganze rüstung und wenn max weg
ist weiß ich nicht ob ich überleben kann
aber wenn man zum plan ausgearbeitet für
max und zwar baut mag sich jetzt in die
säule in der halle 1 versucht durch die
säule hoch zu kommen
die macht und ersichtlich und vielleicht
boxen sich den zwei teams wenn ihr
gleichzeitig gehören
und ja ich versuche dann oben zu treffen
dass unser plan und nicht wie schnell
wieder abgetrennt wird
ok - 193 - abnehmen
also soll ich nach unseren allen bitte
ok sind auf dem server
ich bin schon nicht mehr kriegen wenn
ich dass du mich noch kriegen sehr nice
junge 63
ich kann dir gleich 193 habe ich also
ich bin gerade auf bei koordinaten von
157 154 roboter 154 100 54 157 154 50
jeweils etwas ab
wenn ich irgendwo anders
115 150 euro die sind über mir sind zwei
namen film fährt sie kommen runter leute
wissen nicht dass michael wollte ich an
ihr vorbei wenn es ganz alter ich bin
grad an dem vorbei gelaufen
richard baum gehört ja ich bin über die
darüber gedacht die wegen diesen grad in
die höhe herunter gegangen
die sind jetzt unten und wollen mich
wohl ich sehe ihren armen 160 bei -0 64
52 wochen hoch ich komme mir aber lasst
hast du essen für mich ja ich kann ja
dann lasst bitte lass mich aber unsere
sachen fertig machen hast du ihn dann
machen wir diese hält was auch immer
noch nicht einfach genug ich will mich
nicht ins mieten hier sind die unten
wir sind unten ich sehe nichts wollen
ist es ziemlich dumm werde ich weiter
hoch weil ich habe hier noch ein förster
mein herz pumpt richtig und bin ich
aufgeregt ich weiß gar nicht aufgeregt
wollte ich auch ich mache mut ich habe
zwei vorteile - 160 150 kommt bei hund -
107 50 - 125 150 152 okay dann kommt
dann kommt zu jetzt kriege ich schaden
schon von essen ja aber ich bin auch
keine an der erde also -129 leider kann
egal ich hab' ich habe keins mehr
defizite in astana 54
wir brennen darauf fällt raus wir machen
alles hier dass wir direkt runter können
und die klatschen über 33 ist diese
aktion gerade beeilt nicht boom story
geschrieben meinte so ja wir bieten euch
wechsel aus ich habe es gegeben
du hast den himmel aber okay die leggins
aber nicht mehr aber ich habe ja noch
mal ihr müsst den schnellen ofen machen
die beiden sprint-asse es ist noch nicht
fertig gebracht
problem ich habe mal kräftig pad locker
sind doch die eltern ja und wir wollen
trotzdem feierten
ja aber diese lockerer folge sie wenn ja
und wir holen auch nicht plötzlich 8000
folgen auf das ich werde fighten weil
wir den unsere irgendwie dem wenn wir
fertig kurzen unsere ich sagen ein
problem zumindest noch ein bisschen zeit
um fms zu machen oder zumindest man
wasser einem oder besuchen lagerfeld
dass wir zumindest mal feuer haben
hatte
die sicher
ok also lasst kurz überlegen mache ich
machen was ich habe 52
hier ist der verein kann sein dass die
sich hoch bauen ja theoretisch da hast
du kohle noch oder haye muss musste gar
muss wie viel sie trainer hast du noch
ich habe 42 ist ein getan es vor dass
fischer luftschloss alter aber das team
braucht zu lange und zu brennen junge
ich brauch schnellen der test place du
hast meine ich will trends nicht schaue
erst mal ob du da vorne gibt es im
wasser einmal den kann ich schon mal
holen
erst machen kommt hoch kommt also weiß
was ich mache
ich brauchte mir erstmal einen bogen
macht apple mit
da kann ich mir zumindest noch eine
ladung pfeile machen also in flins tor
nummer drei für 11 zu kriegen weil sie
jung theoretisch kann man die strecke
noch jedes komma nichts denken alles
klar ein citroen schwert und das zweite
hat jetzt auch ballack ist frage ist mit
welchem rüstung die kämpfen wie gesagt
ich sag dir haben teilten locker ja ich
habe natürlich einen vorteil wir müssen
schon zum glück haben können wir die
falten wollen dann werden wollen am ipad
und lesen auch beiden sehr ordentliche
pvp was ich mache mir das nicht so die
kassen chancen aushält gesagt haben
gesagt fighten zumindest man es also
level zufällig ich habe es gerade geholt
einfach abwarten wieder passieren ein
jahr entfernt
ja sagen das abkommen sollen ja dann
sagt mir fehlen noch zwei waren bis zur
agents niemals kommen derzeit hoch okay
wir haben pachten er soll ich jetzt
schreiben oder versuchen für instanzen
bekommen ob jetzt noch ein fenster
direkt fns was es noch ein quintett muss
mir auch ein apple ist er überzeugt ganz
in form eines nehmen sind diesen
bullshit
und ich gebe mir auch mal ein schwert
für den fall dass sie jetzt kannst du da
sind an den verboten meister das erlaubt
das weiß ich nicht ich habe mich sehr
für jetzt mit dem singleplayer
beschäftigt aber ich glaube anderen sind
verboten ja aber klug von ihm sozusagen
vereinfacht oder nett von ihm ist zu
sagen aber einfach sagen können ja klar
ist dennoch versuchen machen
wo genau jetzt sind die auch da wo
kinder kräften und bundestage sind jetzt
auch da wären die folge geht neun
minuten und wird so schlecht die wollten
ja sagen wir unsere court ist jetzt
komplett
ich brenne noch ein bisschen mit hier
man kann kann man auch sein zu brennen
damit du nicht hunger leiden muss man so
ja ich hab einen bogen
aber ich glaube um stalking ums unten
ich hasse das projekt immer so aufgeregt
bin ich bei mir gesagt wenn ihr hier
was kam mit dem citrin noch machen nicht
hast du feierst du feierst feile 2 oder
ich mach dir schnell mal so lang dass
keiner kommt nicht dass jetzt weg ab
gestoppt werden
ich habe vier nach mit 400 wissen fünf
minuten da sind sie ja eh alter [ __ ]
attacke auffallend häufig zentrales
entfernte schon immer irgendwelche noch
bekommen hier unterlagen mit unserem
equipment bist du dumm halo grund ist
immer besser was laut die springreiter
tot
sie hat ihr seht ein kräftiger kurz
einer neuen welt brennt ist es diesen
entrüstung
jetzt will fiat aber aber die geometrien
und teils noch weiter
noch weiter lauf weiter warten ich nicht
eingesehen dass nicht messen lassen was
war das paket alter wo ich bin erstaunt
waren glaub ich habe ein heim ist ein
halbes ich bin oft an sein team
aber der macht sei eine glorreiche ära
geht zu ende
minecraft 1 2 beim nächsten mal